تراجع الثقه في علامات التجميل التي
يملكها المشاهير فمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
عندما يستخدم المشاهير مثلا بعض المنتجات
من ليدي جاجا الى نعومه اوساكا لاعبه تنس
اليابانيه اطلق اكثر من خمسين مؤثر ومشهور
علامه تجاريه لمستحضرات التجميل والعنايه
بالشعر والبشره خلال السنوات الثلاثه
الاخيره فقط لكن اتجاهات المستهلكين تغيرت
ما بعد الجائحه والاهتمام تحول من ادوات
الميك اب لمستحضرات العنايه بالبشره اليوم
استمرار مخاوف الركود تركز المتسوقات على
جوده المنتج اكثر من دعم الترويج النجم
للعلامه
هدف كثير من العلامات التجاريه التابعه
للمشاهير تحقيق سمعه جيده حتى يتم
الاستحواذ عليها من قبل او من قبل عمالقه
شركات التجميل مقابل مبالغ كبيره لكن مع
تشبع السوق
فا
لمزيد سوق مستحضرات التجميل العالميه مع
زميلتنا لميس ابراهيم
من المتوقع عن الموثوق مستحضرات التجميل
العالمي من نحو 398 مليار دولار في 2020
الى 665 مليار دولار بحلول الفين وثلاثين
مستحضرات العنايه بالبشره تتصدر مبيعات
التجميل العالميه منذ الرائحه وفي 2021
كانت مسؤوله عن حوالي 41% من حجم سوق
التجميل العالمي السوق الاسيويه مسؤول عما
يقرب من 35% من السوق العالميه لمستحضرات
العنايه بالبشره وفي عام 2016 من المتوقع
ان تبلغ ارادتها حول العالم نحو 188 مليار
دولار لوريال الفرنسيه هي الشركه الرائده
في مستحضرات التجميل حول العالم خلال 2022
حققت مبيعات تقدر بثمانيه وثلاثين.26
مليار دولار اخيرا الولايات المتحده
مسؤوله عن معظم ايرادات مستحضرات تجميل
العالميه بشكل عام وبحسب من المقرر ان
تتجاوز المبيعات داخل البلاد حجز 91 مليار
دولار خلال 2013 على كل حال من السعوديه
سالنا السيدات هل علامات التجميل مشاهير
تؤثر على قراراتك الشرائيه للمنتجات نتابع
الاجابات
حتى لو كانت تاثر فانا اعتبرها تاثر بشكل
ايجابي انه يعني ما عدا التخلي للامانه او
انا اتكلم عن نفسي شخصيا ما تهمني
البراندات ولا تهمني قديش انا ادفع انا ما
اتخيل نفسي ممكن احط 20 الف شنطه بينما
ممكن العشرين الف تكلفني سفره انا انبسط
فيها ممكن تؤثر عليه اذا كان الشيء اللي
عرضه يناسبني ويناسب احتياجاتي عادي
اشتريه واذا شيء ما يناسبني ما حاشترن
اكيد لا لانه كلها بتكون اعلان ودعايات هم
الكسبانيين فيها لكن المتضررين احنا فيها
لانه بس موضوع انه شهره لهم تمام وياخذوا
عليها مكاسب واحنا اللي قليل العقل هو
اللي بيمشي معاهم زمان كانت تؤثر علي بس
لما شفت ان المصداقيه ما هي عاليه عند
المشاهير ما عاد تسار ياثر فيا صارت عن
تجربه شخصيه ما بهمني المشاهير بيهمني
البراند تكون هي عجبتني او حتى من لوكال
ديزاين ما بتفرق معي صراحه طبعا بالنسبه
لمستحضرات الت جميل لا انا بالنسبه لي
يعني اشوف انها شيء انا مجربته ممكن لانه
مو كل بشره بينفع انها تستخدم نفس البشره
الثانيه ممكن اسمع بس اذا في حاجه معينه
انا حابه انه اشتريها ممكن اخذ عليها
ريفيو او اسمعه كذا بس انها تاثر فيها
كقرار لا
على كل الصحفي الاقتصاديه سمر يسعد صباحك
اهلا بك بالارقام
والاحصاءات كيف يؤثر بالفعل شخص مشهور على
نجح منتج مع مثل ما قلنا في بدايه الخبر
اللي تكلمتوا فيه قبل شوي عن البلوجر اللي
تسوي فلوس هوايه على التيك توك او الى
اخره بالبدايه بالتاكيد هناك شيء يعني
ندرسه بالماركتينغ هو الادراك للمنتج طبعا
هذا الادراك يساهم في عده عوامل منها مثلا
انه دائما تشوفي بالبورد انه يكون يعني
دعايه انه يكون هناك سنبرتي او شخصيه
معروفه واحده من الاشياء خلف هذه المنتجات
ومثل ما ذكرت وحده من الاخوات بالبوكس انه
بالبدايه ممكن ياثر عليك وتروحين تسوين
قرار الشراء بس بس تجيدين انه هذا المنتج
مو بعد التجربه مو مثل مو كلش زين او الى
اخره طبعا ياثر هذا على قرار الشراء
ويتراجع بس طبعا بنفس الوقت منتجات جيده
بس همين بنفس الوقت يعني بعض نذكر مثلا
يعني لما ما يكون في مصداقيه ياثر هوايه
مثلا لما جاءنا تطلع تقول انا كلها احط
زيت زيتون كذا انا بشرتي عمري مثل عمرها
30 سنه يعني ما حد حيصدق هذا الكلام لازم
يكون فيه مصداقيه ولو يعني كل هالراجعه
عشرين سنه اللي ورا من ورا زيت الزيتون
وبعدين طلعت المستحضرات يعني
حتى يعني في حياتنا بتشوف بتسالي برضه
دائما بقولوا لك النوم بنامي بكير فبتضل
هيك على كل حال على كل حال هل اليوم سمر
خفت بريق المشاهير فيما يتعلق بتجاره
مستحضرات التجميل لم نعد نسمع يعني بانه
في هذا المجال هذا الصوت ماشي بالفعل
اليوم يمكن طبعا السبب الرئيسي هو الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه اللي يمر فيها العالم
اجمع خصوصا خلال هذا العام يعني خلال
خلال ثلاث اعوام الماضيه اكثر من 50
سلبريتي او اكثر من 50 شخصيه مشهوره
اطلقوا منتجات خاصه بهم منهم براتبه ما
كنت اعرف انه براتبه عندها منتج خاص اسمه
منتج الشباب انه اسمه خاص بالرجال بس هذا
اكثر واحد لفتني طبعا هناك العديد من
المشاهير الى اخرين بس مثلا عندك هالسنه
باول ربع من السنه احنا صار لنا ثلاث شهور
من السنه بس جون ليجند اطلق براند معينه
للسكن كير اتوقع او شيل العنايه بالبشره
بينما في مثل هذا الوقت العام الماضي كان
هناك خمس مشاهير اطلقوا منتجات جديده ايضا
اليوم يعني تشيل العديد من العلامات
التجاريه اللي هي ريليتا تقريبا ثلاث
علامات تجاريه شالوا السنه الماضيه من
سيفوره اللي هي يدعمها بعض السلبريتيز او
المشاهير خصوصا مشاهير اليوتيوب التيك توك
ايضا تكلمت مع العديد من الاشخاص يعني
اعرفهم يستعملون المنتجات التجميل بقوه
قالوا انه اليوم يعني شويه صاروا ما
يفضلون اتباع
البلوغرز او السلبريتيز على اليوتيوب وعلى
الواتساب لانها مدفوعه فما يحسوها صار
بالعكس يصير هناك ابتعاد انه الماركه
الناجحه هي تتكلم عن نفسها ما تحتاجين
توباكت
بيدعموه تدعميها طبعا عن حجم صناعه
مستحضرات التجميل وشو هي المحركات
الرئيسيه بدايه هناك بس احب انوه الى نقطه
انه صحيح مثل ما قلنا احد المحركات
الرئيسيه هي انه تكون او مدعومه بسلبريتي
بس ليس جميع المشاهير يقدرون اليوم لانه
هم مشغولين جدا ولانه يحتاج لها ديديكيشن
مو كل المشاهير تقدر انه تطلق يعني يمكن
انجح ماركه اللي هي جيسيكا البها الممثله
اعتزلت التمثيل تتمثل بس بنفس الوقت
ماركتها نجحت هوايه من احد العوامل اللي
بتساعد على النجاح هيكون واخلاص وتفرغ
لهذه
المنتجات اليوم حجم هذه الصناعه بس
السكينكر اللي هي اكبر وحده منهم العنايه
بالبشره راح توصل 188 مليار دولار كما
راينا خلال ثلاث سنوات القادمه في اقبال
اكثر على السكين كير والعنايه بالبشره
والشعر بعد كورونا من الميك اب لانه الناس
كلها صار عندها توجهات اكثر على المنتجات
الصحيه ماذا ايضا نادين احنا حبيت انت
يعني دخلتي بدور المذيعه هلا من اليوم لا
بس حتى
ارتبرهم يعني من اليوم على كل حال انا كنت
عم بسمع مركزه معك فشكرا جزيلا لك
وسمر المشط الصحفي الاقتصاديه